All right, Alex, we're going to break
this down. What happened in the middle
of the Super Bowl?
>> Oh, man. You know, there was uh two
different halftime shows. I think this
is the first time that we've ever had
Yeah. Two.
>> Yeah.
>> Two back toback or at at the same time
competing for one another.
>> Yeah. In the leadup to this, I think
they really tried to push this idea that
it was going to be this like really
wholesome family, you know, rubber
stamped good wholesome entertainment
type thing. And uh maybe it wasn't.
Well, that's that's certainly how it was
built. In fact, in the leadup to the
All-American halftime show, um they had
clips playing basically trying to
encourage a return to religion, uh
trying to encourage people's
spirituality. Uh take a listen to this
right here.
Dear Lord, there was a time when the
good news stayed inside church walls.
When believers grew comfortable and
quiet, when the lost walked by unseen,
and heaven felt far away.
In that silence, worldly living was
celebrated, truth was ignored, and
people faced eternity separated from
God. We as Christians are called to go
into the public arena to correct error
with truth. And there's a lot of error.
We're all sinners. I'm far more
interested in what God wants of me than
what I want from God. But now the church
awakens.
She remembers the gospel. She sees the
lost and she rises.
>> Look at all the circle stuff here. I
think it's actually like
>> I think there's actually some sun
symbolism here. Look at all this.
>> You see that?
>> Oh, interesting. workplace
>> unity
>> to take the message of Jesus Christ into
whatever sphere we are in. We are called
to share your truth that eternal
punishment is real but your forgiveness
is greater. That our sin condemns but
Christ alone saves.
Use us Lord to make heaven crowded.
>> Wow.
You know, it's like you can see them
really gearing up to this this, you
know, last struggle is going to be of a
religious order.
>> Yes.
>> I mean, that's what I that's what I see
is it's like this is going to come out
in the public and be very much a part of
our society in the end of time.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> The problem I mean I don't I mean that
all sounds fine.
>> Fine.
>> Really,
>> we want people.
>> They're talking about sharing. This is
what we're called to do as Christians.
You're right. In that respect is like
when you cross the line between sharing
and forcing.
>> Mhm.
>> Yep.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, did you catch the part about
eternal conscious torment though?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. They're throwing the little you're
going to burn if you don't go with our
way.
>> Got to have the pitchfork a little bit
>> over easy, you know.
>> Oh, no.
>> Or I guess make sure everybody's roasted
on both sides evenly.
>> That sun sun imagery that you brought up
was was pretty interesting. Um there's a
lot of things flashed at you. whenever
stuff is flashed at you, you know, your
mind's pretty capable of seeing some
pretty intense quick things.
>> Yeah.
>> But you don't have time to s sit there
and necessarily process it. So, yeah,
there was a lot of like church the the
things that were inside of the domes of
the church and
>> y it's all all all has an interesting
motif to it. But, you know what was
interesting is the all-American halftime
show. It starts off with this kind of
gentiel picture that they're painting of
like this return to spirituality. But
the question is, was it a return to
religion, a return to spirituality? Was
it the true revival that everybody wants
to see? Um, and you know, even when the
singers, you know, Brantley Gilbert,
when he comes out on stage here, um, he
has God, family, country on his t-shirt
there, and he's got a cross around his
neck. Um, so he's again trying to push
forward that image. And that's just
something that you saw consistently with
each of the singers that came out at
this halftime show is that they were
trying to kind of
>> subtly push push God forward. If you
look at um like Christian apparel
companies like Caruso, for example,
they're kind of the big one in in that
space.
>> They have a whole section on their
website that's I guess more geared
towards guys
>> and almost everything is like God and
country. Mhm.
>> Like they're definitely combining
Christian things with
>> um nationalistic ideas.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> So it's all like flags and kind of like
I don't think they have anything with
like guns, but that other companies kind
of like put those together. It's like
Bibles, Bullets, and Bacon, you know,
like
Yeah.
>> You know, um I think he's a country
music artist. Is that is that what he
does?
>> Yeah. I I I don't really know him very
well at all, but um yeah, I mean it just
seemed like a I I clicked on the very
intro of this and it was just like a
solid rock show.
>> Oh yeah. Yeah. No, it very much is a
rock show. But it's also interesting,
you know, when when I look at these I I
have to look at it with an analytical
mind and try and see what kind of
symbolism they're putting out there
because, you know, each Super Bowl in
the past at the halftime shows
>> you know there's I I think you guys have
done videos before talking. It's very
occult and a lot of times it has the the
resemblance of a religious worship
service.
>> Mhm.
>> So you find different symbolisms
throughout it. One of the things I
thought was interesting, you see you see
the snake right there?
>> Yeah. On the base of his microphone.
That's crazy. I didn't catch that when I
saw it actually first, but wow.
>> Yeah. Uh here's a little clip of it.
>> You see it right there?
>> Yeah. And I mean what are they Yeah. But
what do they they never made reference
to it. There was no actual pointed it
out or
>> No. No. No. Um that's interesting. You
know, part of me wonders if I mean this
is a country music artist. Um and you
know, he was talking about guns at some
point in his singing as well. Um part of
me wondered if it was kind of a a throw
to the don't tread on me movement. Um
you know, the second amendment kind of
movement out there. So I'm I'm not going
to, you know, totally say that it's just
you know, completely occult symbolism,
but it is interesting. Nevertheless,
>> interesting. Um, and you also saw him
throwing up the, you know, the devil's
horns there, right, as you see a lot of
rock artists do.
>> You would think they would be sensitive
to that.
>> Yeah.
>> Given the
>> what what what they opened with that
that whole thing, but I didn't I didn't
watch it, so I I can't speak to the
content, but I'm curious, were there any
like Christian songs? Like were there
any hymns? Were there any like was God
mentioned in music? God was mentioned,
but not not hymns as we would typically
think of them. Um, so but you do hear
God mentioned. Take a listen to some of
these next clips here.
>> I was brought up with a small town North
Georgia raised in the Bapt
call. Everybody praise the Lord. Y'all
grew up learn how to hunt and fish. How
to bust a 12 gauge pump and not miss.
>> I know. It's quite It's quite funny.
like I'm in church, but then I got a
shotgun and I ain't going to miss, you
know? It's like what?
>> Yeah.
>> And actually, if you listen to it,
there's actually references to drinking
um in several of the songs actually um
and and uh smoking and things like that.
So, you know, we're not talking about a
a perfectly um converted, right?
>> Squeaky clean
>> no version of No.
>> And and that's what it really seems
like. I see a revival and a return to
godliness of like a character that you
are others focused doing kind acts
towards people. Not just like I'm
signing up with this group over here and
I'm wearing an American flag and I'm
going to pump my shotgun and point it at
you so if you come at me we're going
right
>> like that. This is missing the boat to
me.
>> Right. I mean you know there's there's
not much discussion about dying to self
like what Paul talks about. Um, but you
know there each each of the artists did
talk about God. Take take another listen
here.
>> Watch the evening news
be told if I tell my own daughter that
little boys ain't little girls I'll give
up the freaking hot water in this
world. It ain't easy be country in this
country nowadays.
the directions the fingers point when
everything goes up in flames. Say I'm
some rightwing devil cuz I was down
south Jesus ra
it ain't easy being country
in this country nowadays.
>> So what did the lyrics say? So, did you
catch how he said um you know it's not
easy being country and then he's talking
about um really the transgender movement
talking about you know little girls that
you know can't become little boys type
thing and he's saying like if you say
that it's going to get you in a lot of
hot water um and and then there was also
reference to Jesus in there as well. So
again it's this kind of pushing a
political agenda
>> um and saying you know that this country
has gone too far a certain direction.
Yeah.
>> And we've got to try and bring it back.
>> People feel silenced and and I get that,
but I don't think the solution is to
then turn around and silence everybody
else. You're you're just doing the same
thing that was done to you.
>> Now, we have to be careful with the
critique obviously because as a Bible
believing Christian, I don't believe
that little girls can become little
boys.
>> Yeah.
>> Um but the question is not the the
content right there specifically. It's
where is this overall trajectory going?
>> Right. Right.
>> Right.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And that's why I'm saying
turning around and silencing somebody
else.
>> That's not that's not the solution,
>> right?
>> We need more open dialogue.
>> Mhm. But um you know, there was uh there
was also a lot of stardom present. Uh
you there was a female singer and you
actually saw at one point during the
song where she kind of literally like
points to herself like this. Um, and
there's also when Kid Rock came on
stage, it was one of the most profound
openers for somebody coming on stage
I've seen recently. Take take a look at
this.
Ladies and gentlemen, please welcome our
homie Kid Rock.
>> So, isn't that crazy though? I mean,
>> if you are like unaware of Christian
ideas and you see this, I really wonder
if somebody would walk away and be like,
"Man, that guy was promoting Jesus." He
has like his name up there in lights,
you know, and like Yeah.
>> Well, that much like flare and pageantry
for one person coming out on stage, it
you really do have to question who who
are we worshiping,
>> right? Right.
>> You know, the people that are in
attendance there who are screaming out
for him and in in excitement to come on
stage. But I mean, this isn't something
that's specific to just this this thing.
I mean, this would happen with any Super
Bowl performance. I mean,
>> but but to brand it as this wholesome
family event
>> to me is like you you you didn't really
do that.
>> No, no, no.
>> It was just a rock show with a bunch of
people that identify as Christian,
>> right? Yes. Um,
>> but you had uh you had another song here
where it got a little bit slower and
they were talking again about a return
to religion.
>> One Sunday morning all alone with this
song stuck in my head
and in that moment something or someone
spoke to me.
They said there was still a verse that
needed to be written for this song
and to get up
and write it down.
There's a book that's sitting in your
house somewhere that could use some
dusting off.
There's a man who died for all our sins
hanging from the cross.
You can give your life to Jesus and
he'll give you a second chance till you
can't
take it.
If you got a chance,
take it. Take it while you got a chance.
If you got a dream,
chase it cuz a dream won't chase you.
>> I'm just thinking about what the words
he just said there. If you got a dream,
chase it because a dream won't change
your past.
Like, I wonder what he's meaning by
that.
>> Well, the whole the whole rest of the
song he's actually talking about like um
you know, you can spend time with your
loved ones until you can't. You know,
you can fix up that old car that you've
been meaning to till you can't. And then
so he's basically saying you need to
dust off your Bible. Don't wait. You
know, it's a it's let's it's you got to
take this seriously, you know, which
overall I mean yeah, we would agree with
that message 100%.
>> Um but where where is the overall
trajectory of this going? I appreciate
the message that he was trying to put
forward, but in some ways I'm sitting
there going, there's kind of a problem
with that picture. If he says, you know,
you got a book in your house, you need
to dust off. If you're all gathered to
hear under this banner of Christianity,
>> Mhm.
>> you're the last group of people that
should need to have your Bibles dusted
off.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. You guys are the ones that should
be reading them. So, if you if you're
into this whole movement and you're not
reading your Bible, that's that's where
the problem is.
>> Yeah.
>> I think he was trying to tell the
audience that they needed to do that.
And so, it was like this is what you
guys need to do. But the audience in
attendance supposedly, I mean, wouldn't
you like if you're going to a concert,
you're going because you appreciate that
artist, right? If you're going to this
halftime show, it's because you
appreciate what they're trying to
accomplish. Like you already believe in
that thing.
>> Mhm.
>> So, the message to me, it's like you're
you should be kind of speaking to the
choir.
>> There's probably very few in terms of
the percentage of Christianity as a
whole that actually study on an ongoing
basis.
>> Yeah. But, you know, the Bible says,
"Study to show thyself approved."
>> Mhm.
>> So, I mean, we all have that duty to go
and uh and uh be in our Bibles.
>> Yeah. Yeah. You know, it's like you you
hear them say, "Okay, we want we want
you to sign up with Christianity. We
want you to make Jesus your king and
lord." Um but is Jesus changing your
life? I think that's really what's
what's at the heart of this thing.
>> What that means is all is outlined in
scripture, right?
>> Yeah. We we don't even know what that
means if we're not taking the rest of
the Bible into account. So if we're not
reading it and we're just saying
>> Jesus is important, which he is, totally
agree with that. Jesus is is paramount.
>> Yeah.
>> But what that means is defined in
scripture for us
>> because the Bible gives us a warning
that says that there will be a
classification of people that have the
form of godliness but deny the power.
The power to the gospel is to change.
Like what does that mean if you're like,
"Okay, I'm I'm I'm Christian, but it
doesn't really affect my life. I still
drink, smoke, party, do whatever I want
to do, throw up devil horns in the
middle of my Jesus song." Like, there's
no heart change. And I hope that that's
not the case with with here. But, you
know, it's like I really wish that they
would promote the idea of when you when
you actually live like Jesus wants you
to live, it's a radical difference than
what we are actually probably as a
nation experiencing.
>> Yeah. When you look at chapters like
Matthew 7 and Jesus is talking to a
group of Christians in that chapter,
he's saying, "Depart from me, you who
practice lawlessness." You know, I never
knew you. That that's kind of a very
stark reality.
>> And they're doing wonderful things.
That's why he said, you know, if you're
casting out demons in my name or you're,
you know, doing all of these wonderful
works in my name, he says that
>> not just having a label. Well, you know,
2 Corinthians 3 talks about how he will
write on on our tables of our heart.
That's right.
>> Um, and so it there is supposed to be a
change that takes place, you know,
imputed and imparted righteousness that
that God can come within us and change
us if we but let him. Um, and that's
something that is is often given the
sideline.
>> That's right. We have a country that is
moral country. It's a country that loves
their church, that loves their flag. And
it seems like this the entertainment
industry has just missed that population
entirely and that these big shows and
these big performances often miss and
more importantly insult those people.
>> Yeah. Or even more so, they kind of give
you a link that they don't want you to
bring that into your performance, right?
You give a nod to God or something like
this. And and I I know there's going to
be arguments out there. Kid Rock, talk
about Jesus. Yeah, love Jesus. Of
course. I don't remember that in the Ten
Commandments, it said, "Thou shalt not
drink or thou shalt not curse." I might
represent a little bit of the uh the
more open side of the conservatives.
That's okay, too.
>> Wow.
I mean, once again, I think it's like it
it's going to become this thing that's
not a morality issue, so to say, as much
as you're signing up on this side of the
fence or not.
>> Yeah.
>> What colors are you wearing? Blue or
red? You know, and it's like the
>> it's it's not much change in the heart,
>> right? You know, there's uh verses out
there like wine is a mock or strong
drink is raging. Hesoever who drinks
thereof is not wise. And also, we know
that at the end there's imagery in
Revelation talking about this harlot
that has a cup filled with abominations,
filled with with wine. And that wine,
>> it's false doctrine. It's false
teachings, right? um wine actually uh
there's a there's a verse it is not for
kings Omuel it is not for kings to drink
wine lest they forget the law.
>> Yeah.
>> And so there's this this notion that
drinking actually makes us forget God's
law.
>> And you know David says on thy law do I
meditate day and night. So when I think
of him saying like ah you know this is
this is okay. Um I I think that there's
adequate proof in scripture that God
wants us to have clear. I mean, are we
not told to be sober minded?
>> Yeah. And there's there's enough medical
evidence that suggests that smoking is
also going to shorten your lifespan. So,
now you get into like, well, when you
say, "Thou shalt not kill, does that
include yourself?"
>> When the Bible says your body is the
temple of the Holy Spirit,
>> does it need to be filled with your
cigarette smoke?
>> That's a question, you know, same as
it's like asking the drinking question.
But to paint the overall picture, I
think what you're seeing again though,
like we talked about, is this pendulum
that is swinging towards a more com
combined church and state union.
>> We see that that's what kind of happened
with with um you know the Israel that
they went away from God, they were
punished, sent away to Babylon and then
when they came back they were like let's
not do that again. And then they started
writing all these laws and those laws
really help people. I mean, they just
got nitpicky and small and then all of a
sudden it was this disastrous situation
when Jesus was was coming on the on the
earth the first time. So,
>> um I think we're headed down that.
>> Yeah. Yeah, we are. So, at the end of
the um All-American halftime show, they
had a little homage to Charlie Kirk and
that was again kind of the whole point
of this, right? Was an homage to him.
I want to honor God in all that I do. I
want to be a great husband, a great
father. I want to serve this country. I
want to try to continue to lead this
movement and to speak truth and to never
lie. To stop thinking about yourself all
the time and said, "Think about what you
should do to help other people and to
defend this country above yourself." I'm
so inspired. This army of freedom
fighters, we're going to be around for
the next 100, 200 years because we know
in the end our ideas will win.
>> God should be the most important thing
in your life. But then beyond that, it's
getting married, having children,
building families. My kids are my most
important thing in the world. My wife
and my kids, our relationship with God,
the top three things. And the more often
that you choose the deep, the difficult,
but the right path over the easy path is
one that will reward you, your family,
and this beautiful nation.
I like what he said, but he said a
couple of key important words.
>> One is he talked about freedom, but then
he also said, "Choose." That's what
freedom does is it allows for choice.
>> Yeah. And that's that's you know you're
talking about where is this whole thing
going
>> right?
>> It's not going the direction of choice
when you look at what people are saying
and when you look at the imagery that
they're putting out and yeah and that's
that's something to highlight is is
we've asked the question you know where
is this change going now we have to
answer it and show what direction are
these Christian which actually I have a
clip about Charlie Kirk's stance on
Christian nationalism. Okay.
>> Um, but where is that movement as a
whole going?
>> Yeah.
>> But but before we get there, you know,
there were two halftime shows.
>> There were.
>> And I didn't watch that one either.
>> And so, yeah. No. So, you had you had
Bad Bunny's performance, which Bad Bunny
is a is a Puerto Rican singer. So,
Puerto Rico is a US territory. Okay. It
is.
>> Um, and so, you know, but everything
that he sang basically was in Spanish.
Um, and he also had Lady Gaga singing
there with him and she sung some in
English, but you know, I I believe you
guys just did a recent episode actually
about Bad Bunny and talked about his uh
his music style. What are your thoughts
about his music style?
>> Yeah, it was just like what he was into
and you know, he's he does some really
shocking things like puts a third eye on
his forehead. Well, if you know what
that means, that that's like opening up
your communication to evil spirits. Yes.
You know, and and you know, his music is
very sensual and sexual in nature and
>> Right. Yeah. He's very fluid in the way
that he dresses.
>> Exactly. He's male female thing gets
blurred.
>> Yeah. He's he's promoting a lot of the
things that TPUSA was not promoting.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. Yeah.
>> Right.
>> Um, so
>> do you think that that's purposeful
though that they all of a sudden now
they have these two opposite ended
worlds, so to say, and they're like,
>> you know, I don't know. I I I think it
goes back to the whole,
>> you know, Daniel thing, right? The the
king of the north, king of the south,
waring against each other. They're these
two totally different mindsets.
>> Exactly. Exactly.
>> I I 100% think that the devil was behind
both. I think they tried to have
Christian imagery in the one, but the
overarching sentiment is not one that is
inherently Christian. Again, they're
talking about drinking. They're talking
about smoking. It's glorification of
self. They're having a snake on stage,
right?
>> Throwing up devil horns. throwing up
devil horns. Okay. So, there's all this
imagery that is antithetical to true
Christianity
>> and at the same time with Bad Bunny's
performance, I mean, it's more so
>> it's more so, right? Um, so you have
extremely provocative sensual dancing
dancing like him right here on this on
this pickup truck, you know, in the
middle of this uh this field. Um, and
you have, you know, all the the
provocative female dancers that are are
dancing. So you have two sides to the
same coin
>> being shown. And I think that this play
off of each other was for a specific
reason. It was for a specific narrative.
Um and I I also think it's not helping
to unite the country either. Now there's
a lot of people that are going to look
at this and say he's Puerto Rican.
That's a US territory. I mean it's all
American to have him here. You know, we
should celebrate our US territories. But
there's other people that that are going
to look at this and say, "Oh, he's he's
singing in a in Spanish. You know, this
is an American country. We need to have
everybody speaking English." And it's
going to further fment
>> the divide about the immigration issue
that is currently ongoing. Um, so you
also had something interesting that
happened during the uh halftime show.
You actually had a wedding take place.
Has that ever happened? I've never even
heard of that happening at the Super
Bowl halftime show that a marriage is
happened.
>> No, it was I I remember watching this
and thinking like this is really odd.
Like I don't even know what's going on
here. Like why what is this motif? And I
think it's kind of funny though. He has
this grass stuff in here. So all the
performance is happening right there.
Like you're sitting on the ground floor,
you can't see what's in the middle of
this thing. What are they what are they
meaning by all this? Like I don't know.
>> Yeah, it was really interesting. Um, but
there was a there was actually an
article by ESPN talking about how this
couple that got married, they were
legally married during the halftime
performance. Um, this was on ESPN. So,
you know, we've known though previously
that there's been people that have
talked about the Super Bowl halftime
show being a religious ceremony. I
wasn't there someone who said um this
was like the largest church service. It
was like a church
>> Oh, yeah. Madonna. She said that, you
know, she was talking on um I can't
remember which uh which uh talk show it
was at the time, but yeah, she was
describing it as this is this is church.
It's happens on Sunday,
>> you know, and the way that there is
music and all that, those are very much
so associated with worship, worship
ceremonies. So yeah, to have a wedding
in the middle of this thing is like
weird because, you know, the Bible also
says like in the end, right, people will
still be marrying, giving in marriage,
drinking and all that stuff, right? I I
think there was like a little bar he
came by and took a shot and all this
like so yeah he's he's putting religious
imagery out in this thing.
>> Yes. Interesting.
>> So really we could say that both
halftime shows had some religion mixed
in.
>> This is true.
>> They did.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Um, but you had uh Donald Trump
posting on Truth Social talking about
the Super Bowl halftime show with Bad
Bunny and saying that it was absolutely
terrible, one of the worst ever, and it
makes no sense and is a freight to the
great an affront to the greatness of
America. Basically just going on
decrying it. And I think part of the
reason for that is because it was
probably in Spanish and he views it as
an attack against the immigration uh
crisis that's going on. Um so again it's
further fmenting a specific divide
nationally
>> to have these two contrasting
performances. One that is like the most
deep south all-American country got my
shotgun and my beer and everything else
and the other one you know which is
basically foreign essentially.
>> Yeah. But coupling a lot of those ideals
that people who are Christian don't
appreciate.
>> Yes. Yes. M
>> y so you know but the the important
question though is again
where is all of this going? I was uh I
was looking and doing a little bit of
research and I ran across this video by
Sky News actually um and it was Charlie
Kirk and the surge in Christian
nationalism. And so take a listen to
what the host the the investigator here
for Sky News has to say about this surge
of Christian nationalism. into an icon
of free speech and a rallying cry for a
nationalist cause.
>> There are a lot of vigils on this trip,
but it's maybe in the smaller scale that
you get a better sense of how Kirk's
activism penetrated quite so far and
what effect it might continue to have.
>> Charlie Kirk has become really a martyr,
not just for Americans, but I think that
for these nationalist movements across
the the world. speak to some people and
they'll say Charlie Kirk, you know, was
hateful and what he said um made people
feel uncomfortable and scared um
especially when it comes to specific
issues like gay marriage or Islam,
things like that.
>> Do you think that's fair?
>> So, the Bible says that we're to share
the truth and the Bible also says that
do not be surprised when the world hates
you. when you do take a Christian
foundation of western civilization and
that's shipped around the world uh and
Islam which is basically anti
antithetical to that in numerous ways
and then also besides Islam you the gay
marriage aspect of it we believe that uh
according to Christian values that
marriage is between one and one man one
woman and that's natural and right and
given to us by god
>> so what were your thoughts there
>> I think that when you see people and the
reason why they would jump on this this
this wagon, you can understand why
they're wanting that. You know what I
mean? Like he's he's not saying
something that's not true,
>> right?
>> Like we should be, you know, having God
as our foundation and and our
understanding of what we're doing and
why we're doing it and
>> but how we implement that is the key.
>> Exactly. There's a fine line between
this is what I believe and then this is
what I think you need to believe. Like
that's going to be the problem. And
that's that's you know, you look at the
life of Jesus and that's what I see as
very prevalent. Jesus didn't go like
straight to the government to try to
reform it and change it and set up his
kingdom that way. He went to individuals
to help change them because Jesus was
dealing with yeah some of these moral
issues like sin in the life that you
know degrading humanity
>> but he didn't go through the government
to do it. He gave people direct access
to God.
>> Yeah. You're actually bringing up
something that's kind of interesting. I
didn't think about this before, but look
at the look at how the Jewish nation
responded. Like they actually were the
government and then they started being
like, "You can't talk that. You can't
preach that. You can't say that.
>> In fact, we'll throw you in jail." And
they'll throw them in jail and they get
out, you know, and it's like it's like
the way that that happened during
Jesus's day, I'm sure is going to get
repeated.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Um, you know, you have in in my
mind, if you were the devil and you
wanted to push society to a more
religious side of things, of course, you
would first swing the pendulum the other
way. You know, you would say, "Okay,
let's let's just do some crazy stuff.
Like, let's just make people think
they're the wrong gender. like let's
let's you know have all this rampant
immoral decline
>> and as a reaction to that
>> the people will happily accept
>> exactly
>> a return but it'll have religion of
aversion yes
>> and also if you separate them far enough
from the real true Christian gospel and
the and the thing they if they're truly
not reading their Bibles they do not
really like have that heart connection
everything sounds plausible.
>> Sure. So then all of a sudden when the
pendulum does swing back, it's like you
can hand them whatever form of
Christianity and they'll be like, "Oh
yeah, sure. Totally."
>> Yep.
>> But you know, um there's been some
people that have kind of been back and
forth about whether or not Charlie Kirk
was actually a Christian nationalist.
Some people say, "Oh, no, he was not a
Christian nationalist." Other people
say, "Oh yeah, he definitely was." So I
was looking through some of his
interviews that he did with students
before his demise. Um and I found this
one right here where he actually kind of
addresses the the topic head on. take a
listen to what he thought about uh
Christian nationalism.
>> How are you?
>> Good. Uh my name is Nick. I'm an
aerospace engineering student here. Um
got a couple questions. That's all
right.
>> So I'm particularly concerned about your
brand of Christianity as a Christian
myself. Um Christian nationalism I do
not agree with at all. Um I think it's
antithetical to the values of the early
church. And I think how do you reconcile
the es especially white Christians in
this America marrying politics and power
with their faith in this country?
>> There's a lot there. I've never
described myself as a Christian
nationalist. So I'm a Christian and a
nationalist. So I never used those two.
>> And then right there that and
nationalist. Where in the scriptures
does a Christian
>> Thank you. Jeremiah 29:7. Demand the
welfare of the nation that you are in
because your welfare is tied to your
nation's welfare.
That's kind of an interesting point. Is
that really what the verse says?
>> Well, I don't actually know we make a
comment on that.
>> I've never heard somebody actually throw
that out there before. So,
>> I mean, we're right here. We curious of
that.
>> He said 297
>> 29 is that what? Yeah.
>> And seek the peace of the city where I
have caused you to be carried away
captive and pray the Lord of it for in
its peace you will have peace. I don't
think that's what he said though. Did he
say 11? No, that he would he he demand
the peace of the Yeah, that is the verse
he's quoting.
>> No, it says it doesn't say demand here.
It says and seek the peace.
>> So So see what I mean? See what I mean?
Like you're now telling the people.
>> So
>> demand and seek. Yeah. One is one is
like be be subservient
this this punishment that I'm giving to
you
>> and don't be not peaceful. But but he's
using it in a way of saying, "I'm going
to stand up and disrupt the peace to
make order."
>> I said Greek. I should have said Hebrew.
It's in the Old Testament. It looks like
it is an imperative verb. Second person,
masculine, plural. Seek with care, care
for, inquire about, investigate, be
intent on, make supplication.
>> Doesn't have quite the same ring to it.
>> It does not.
>> Doesn't sound like demand any of that.
>> No. So I'm not sure what translation
he's going from.
>> Yeah. And again the question is is how
how I mean this is a a broad
prerogative, right? How is this actually
implemented? So I was looking up cuz I
was like okay well we don't want to
stray into combination of church state
power. And I wanted to know what he
believed about combination of church
state power. Take a listen to his stance
here on on this. And I think this
actually shifted over time because
initially I'm pretty sure he was pretty
pro-separation of church and state but
his views shifted over time.
>> The context of that chapter and verse is
the Jews are about to be taken captive
or already have been taken captive to
Babylon.
>> Okay? Because this is the same chapter
where we read Jeremiah 29:11. This is
the chapter that Daniel would have been
reviewing when he was taken captive in
Babylon in Daniel chapter 9. And he's
praying for his nation. He's saying, you
know, I've been reading and I I think he
specifically
if he doesn't mention Jeremiah, he
quotes from Jeremiah. So, we know that
he was reading in Jeremiah.
And when it's saying, "Seek the peace of
the city." City different than a nation,
right? Mh.
>> Although Babylon was its own nation, but
he's saying, "Seek the peace of
Babylon." In other words, you're there.
You're going to be there. You're going
to be there for a while.
>> Don't be disruptive.
>> Go along. And that was that was kind of
Jeremiah's message to to the Jews was
like, you need to go along with the
program because you've already passed
the point of no return.
>> Yeah.
>> You're going to Babylon.
>> Yeah. So make the best of your situation
>> while you're there,
>> which is a different context than you
know you live in a country so demand
>> something.
>> If you watch further in that interview
actually the the student um advocates
basically that we shouldn't go to war
essentially. He he argues more of a
pacifist kind of approach as a Christian
and Charlie was kind of disagreeing with
him there. It was it was interesting to
see the back and forth and you know
Charlie for for all the people that love
and hate him he was a very good debater.
Yeah. Um at the end of the day um he was
very good at that.
>> But take a listen to his stance on
separation of church and state because
that's where the rubber really meets the
road is well how far does this go then?
>> Yeah.
>> Hi there. Uh my name is
>> and then we got to wrap soon. It's
getting like
>> Yeah. Hope you're doing well. Um so my
question was about separation of church
and state. Um so I know I did some
research. I I've researched your
positions. I know you've come out and
said you don't believe in the separation
of church and state and um I'd like to
ask you why even though there's the
non-establishment clause uh freedom of
religion uh and then there's you know
lawsuits in the like historically like
angle versus vital that come out to say
that church and state should be
separated.
>> It's a fair question. So I don't believe
in a national church. More importantly
let's forget church and state.
>> Can we both agree there is no separation
between morality and state?
>> I agree. It's just lawmaking.
>> That that's cool. That's where I really
live in. What I'm saying is the problem.
Yeah. Yeah. That's what I mean by that
because teetering on some fine line.
>> People are going to have to make a
decision of what is good and what is
bad, what is permissible and not
permissible. And I think the church or
Christianity should inform those
decisions.
>> So, okay, I I understand where you're
coming from and it's undeniable that
there's been a heavy Christian influence
on our nation, right? Um I think 55 out
of 56 founding fathers. You know my
stuff.
>> I do. Yeah. I' I've looked at your
stuff. Yeah. But where I disagree is
putting the Ten Commandments in
classrooms, you know, things like that.
>> Well, so let's let's pause on that if
that's okay. Yeah. I'm guessing you're
not a Christian. That's okay.
>> I'm Hindu.
>> That's fine. So even as a Hindu, what
moral objection to the ten commandments
could there would you agree if everybody
followed the ten commandments better
place to live?
>> For sure.
>> I So there's obviously commandments like
thou shalt not kill. I mean these are
just moral standards that
>> I think in Hindu philosophy
>> the only one that would be is you know
don't take any other gods before me
being a polytheistic fa faith right
having no idols that would violate
Hinduism right
>> but I mean honoring your father and
mother Hindus are pretty good with that
right we try
>> uh not coveting right uh not stealing
not committing adultery I imagine that's
against Hindu religious teaching right
what I'm getting at is despite the
monotheism that is embedded in the ten
commandments you can agree that it does
have good external moral teaching Right.
>> Mhm.
>> And that's what I'm getting at.
>> And this is where it's so tricky because
when you look at our legal system and
you look at our laws, there are laws
that that largely govern, you could say,
the last six.
>> Yes.
>> Because those affect our peopleto-people
relationships. And we have to guard
those people-to-people relationships
>> because yeah, you shouldn't be going
around just killing whoever you want.
That is just wrong, right? But but
here's the tricky part is he says should
morality ever have separation of church
and state. The problem is is the
government has no way to enforce
morality.
They can enforce only outward civic
behavior.
>> Yes. I think the I think the tricky part
is some of those things are also moral.
Well, but but take for example adultery.
Okay, this is part of the last six.
>> Yes. And I I think I know where you're
going with this, but go ahead.
>> You you can you can ban pornography. You
can ban uh prostitution. You can ban all
that stuff. And as a moral a as a as a
part of the fabric of society, yes,
those things should be done.
>> But does the government enforce
adultery? No.
>> No, they can't.
>> But they do deal with the fallout of
adultery.
>> Oh, they do. Yes, they and we deal with
that in the legal system all the time.
We deal with like this the situation
with divorce, what happens with children
and all that. So, and that's all I'm
getting at. I'm not saying we should
enforce, right, you know, every
nitty-gritty detail when it comes to
morality, but we do. There are things
that we enforce that are also moral.
>> The um
>> and so it's it's it's like a very tricky
like balance in all of that. And and the
thing is is like the government can't
enforce like if you want to if you have
murderous thoughts,
>> right?
>> They can't control that, right? If you
have adulterous thoughts, if you have
covetous thoughts, they can't control
it. So in inherently
>> um the the law is only outward civic
behavior. And I think that that's where
it needs to be left.
>> Yeah. just just as an aside.
>> So he's he's advocating that the church
inform the government then the
government enforces the the issue. So
he's trying to say that this has a place
in the seat of of the government
understanding where the lines are.
>> Yeah. And the thing is like when it
comes to like covetousness like this is
like you're saying it's it's start.
>> So how how would you you can't enforce
that
>> right? One of the important actually one
of the important distinctions is that
back in 1888 you had Senator Henry Blair
who was bringing forward the National
Day of Rest. It was it was his
recommendation for a Blair Sunday bill.
You had two proponents uh against Sunday
laws who went in to discuss with him. It
was at Jones and EJ Wagner. And if you
read through their argument section,
their main argument was that the
government cannot ever enforce morality.
Their main argument was they can only
ever legislate outward civic behavior.
That was their thesis
>> for it. Which is why I'm kind of saying
it so strongly, if that makes sense, is
like it's only ever outward civic
behavior that the government has rule
over because again, they can't control
your your
>> and what I and I, you know, I'm just
being completely transparent here. What
I have what I struggle with is
describing that in a succinct way
because some of those things that we do
enforce have moral components to them.
>> Yes.
>> So like for example, yes,
>> murdering people, stealing from people,
those kind of thing. And that's on the
flip side of the coin like you're
talking about
>> adultery often times is a consensual
thing.
>> Yes.
>> Right. So the boundaries being crossed
are agreed upon between two parties
>> and so well that that's those those
people's choice but when you take
something from me you've crossed a
boundary whether it be a life or
property right and so that's that's
where it's like you have to be very
careful how you define the language like
I'm not an advocate for the government
enforcing adultery or those things but
when it comes to like crossing those
boundaries of your fellow man
>> yeah That's important to safeguard that.
And they also happen to be maybe that's
the best way to describe it. They also
happen to be moral things. Yes.
>> But what they're not making a
distinction for is the first four.
>> Yes.
>> And so all of a sudden if you're now,
you know, saying, okay, it's okay for
them to meddle in this area of the thing
and it's crossing over into the now you
need to go to church. That's where I
think total problem.
>> Big problem. Um, but you know, as we go
forward, you're going to see though this
push by the Christian nationalist
movement to legislate all 10 of the Ten
Commandments. And that's what their main
push is is because because it inherently
gets kind of messy if you try and divide
it up in any sort of way. So they're
like, "Oh, well, clearly we have to
legislate the entire thing."
>> Um, you know, and so they don't see the
dividing line between the first four and
the last six.
>> Yeah. It's just easier. Yeah.
>> I you know you I don't know if you're
going to play those clips of of of them
putting the ten commandments back in the
in the church.
>> Um
>> yeah, I want you to show this clip and
then and then I I Yeah, I think it's
very interesting because if we are now
starting to discuss the enforcement of
this whole entire uh ten commandments as
a whole,
>> this is going to be problem.
>> Yes, it is. So So this is actually uh
them um putting these ten commandments
up in Fort Worth, Texas. Okay.
>> Um, and this is them unveiling it right
here.
>> It's pretty good size.
>> Large.
>> Okay. Now,
these ten commandments right here um are
one example, but then you actually have
um previous discussion about this
because this isn't the first time this
has been done. There's been other places
that have
>> been putting them up.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Um, but the thing is
is you'll find some variance
>> between the different stone monuments
that are put up. So, for example, here's
just a kind of I think this is like a
stock image right here. But if you read
the little caption down below, because
this this whole article here is Texas
families of different faith sue over law
requiring ten commandments in
classrooms. But if you look down there,
they give an example image and then they
have a little caption and the little
caption says, "The Ten Commandment
monument erected in 1956 at Albert Lee's
Central Parks sits nestled among a
cluster of overgrown pine trees and they
have a picture of that Ten
Commandments." What do you notice that's
different about this version of the Ten
Commandments that they have?
>> Third commandment. They're saying about
Sunday law.
>> It It says, well, it says remember the
Sabbath day to keep it holy. Which one's
actually the fourth commandment?
>> The Sabbath day. Remember the Sabbath
day to keep it holy. That's the third.
Not the third.
>> Not the third. Third's uh honor. No,
third's do not take the Lord's name in
vain.
>> Depends on which Bible you're reading.
If you're reading the Catholic Bible,
it's going to read that way.
>> So to Charlie Kirk, who is saying that
the ten commandments is where we get
this morality that has to be pushed on
society. The question then must be asked
which ten commandments
>> which and then also ask you know was
that God's goal or intention.
He doesn't he doesn't talk about having
the ten commandments enshrined at a
building. He talks about it being
written on your heart.
>> Yeah.
>> How do you enforce that? Again it goes
back to like the thoughts of
covetousness. You can't enforce that,
>> right?
>> Yeah. You know that God is that's why
God is the judge.
>> Now, you're going to get some people
that say, "Oh, you guys are splitting
hairs over nothing. Of course, the
government can try and legislate as much
as they can, and of course, we have to
leave the rest up to God. People have
been breaking laws since the foundation
of laws, and you know, we just have to
do the best that we can." Um, well, what
how far do you go then? Because you
could tell everybody to go to church on
Sunday or you could have all businesses
closed on Sunday.
>> You could. And that's been done in this
in the in the history of this nation
where you have blue laws. In fact, you
still have blue laws on the books.
>> Um but then you have a discussion about
well which day is the correct day to
worship on because Charlie Kirk for much
of his life which you know he just came
out with this book postumously there was
this book talking about um stop in the
name of God talking about the Sabbath.
Which day do you keep? Is it the seventh
day or the first day? Mhm.
>> And he traditionally or I should say
recently understood the Sabbath meaning
the seventh day of the week.
>> He did but his book
>> even though his book Yeah. That's a
that's a probably a whole another hour
of discussion. His book was was was
meaning that as Sunday.
>> Yeah.
>> So he himself observed Sabbath but
Sunday as well because of his family.
>> His book makes it clear that there's no
that he doesn't think it matters which
day um that that you keep. and and also
says that the the Sabbath shifted over
to Sunday. And
>> so is that where the six seven came
from? I can't.
>> No, that's funny. Well, and then it
depends on what calendar you're looking
at, too, because depending on the
society that you're living in, they have
Monday is the first day of the week and
Sunday is the seventh, you know, so you
get into a whole mess of stuff,
>> right? Right.
>> That people don't agree on,
>> right? But you know this is an important
topic because we even have the White
House which posted here just within the
last little bit saying the United States
is a country founded on faith and sher
shared moral obligation to God.
President Trump will ensure that never
changes. So again that word moral
morality
you know we we we we sat here having a
discussion kind of teasing out the
nuances of morals and morality.
This is important for us to understand.
We do have to have a a right
understanding of where does our morality
come from and who imposes it.
>> You know, if you just observe Jesus,
right, this is all Jesus's king and and
you know, we need to do what Jesus did.
Well, Jesus didn't walk around and try
to like bend the government of the day
>> to force something. He was an
invitational like let me present the
truth to you and you need to make a
decision kind of thing.
>> Mhm.
>> Yeah. And some walked away sorrowful.
Yeah, because they didn't like what he
>> said. And he didn't say, "Guard, stop
that guy right there. I just told him
the truth." And he didn't respond to it,
you know, like
>> throw him in prison. Yeah.
>> Now, there was a few different clips
that came out of the Turning Point, you
know, um conventions that they've been
holding, the kind of the meeting places
that they've been holding um for these
uh turning point action uh summits that
they've been having. Take a listen to
some of the rhetoric that has been
coming out of these places.
He said we should have a day of rest or
honor the Sabbath.
And he said we need people on the front
lines fighting for freedom. We have not
yet tried to create the Christian nation
that America may yet become. the depth
of understanding of this topic uh is
amazing and how he weaves in the Bible
and how he reads in uh just weaves in
all these different interesting facts
and history of the Sabbath and then even
certain laws like blue laws that we had
here in this country.
>> The best way to restore it is to return
and restore those foundations to return
God to the top and to remember who we
are beneath him. And I have to tell you,
Jack, I've prayed so many times, so many
times to Charlie and to and to God to
give me the right guidance on how to
handle this whole thing.
>> How powerful is that? How profound is
that?
>> Amen.
>> Boys will be boys, and there's nothing
wrong with that.
>> Is that Cardi? Is that Is that Cardi B?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> I'm sorry. I was just like shocked there
for a second. Cardi B is giving giving
religious advice now. I'm actually
shocked and I'm not very genuinely
shocked. Is she religious?
>> She is is tending that direction.
>> Cardi B.
>> She's
>> We're talking about the one that doesn't
This is not Cardi B. This is Nicki
Minaj.
>> Nicki Minaj.
>> I thought Cardi B was at the White
House, though.
>> I think she was. Yeah, she was. I'm
sorry. That was Nicki Minaj.
>> That was Nicki M. So, she's too
Christian.
>> Wow. I guess I'm a little out of the
loop here.
>> Yeah.
>> Are you serious?
>> Yeah. Well, but you know, we have seen
this return to religion from uh a lot of
different people. You know, um for
example, one of the ones that I saw was
um
>> Bear Grills actually, you know, the
popular survivalist guy.
>> Um he actually uh was having discussion
about Christ and saying that Christ was,
you know, this this warrior kind of
spirit because he went through this
tremendous torture on the cross and
everything else. And during one of the
clips, he actually said like, so you
know, we all have that kind of warrior
spirit within us that that Christ had.
And I I was listening to him. I was
like, well, Christ had that because he
had the divine and that's how he could
endure that, you know. Um but anyway, uh
there is there's a lot of
Christianication Christianification of
um a lot of popular celebrities out
there,
>> you know. Um, but there's also been more
discussion about these Christian
nationalists and there's been clips that
we have been able to gather to kind of
try and show, you know, we I have uh my
podcast Heritage and Hope Ministries and
so we put together this little
compilation of clips right here. Um,
basically showing where this Christian
nationalist movement is going. Take a
listen to this uh these these clips and
and see if you can pick out an overlying
thread throughout all of it. Well,
you're a Christian nationalist. You want
you want the kingdom to be the
government. YES. YOU WANT GOD TO come
and overtake the government. Yes. Guilty
is charged.
>> Don't actually don't need like a
majority support of the population. You
just need a strong willed minority. And
then th that ruling class can shape the
imagination of the majority. There's a
lot of people who will just kind of
shift with the imagination set by the
people the the ruling class. All the ten
commandments must be legislated and make
make it um clear to everyone which
Sabbath we're we're in favor of that
>> civil law can also include I think
blasphemy laws, Sunday Sabbath laws.
People ask me what laws would you want?
I I think having blue laws, the the
Sunday Sabbath laws really is the first
Yeah.
>> thing that happened. Like it's not
blasphemy laws. on, you know, laws
against heretics and
>> how he weaves in all these different
interesting facts in history of the
Sabbath and then even certain laws like
blue laws that we had here in this
country. Um, and how we have changed
without having that rest built into our
country.
>> You're the people that I want to hear.
That's why we go to church on Sundays
that you should be the most powerful
people on earth.
>> They say separation between church and
state. They told me, I said, "All right,
let's forget about that for one time.
We're bringing religion back to our
country.
>> We might structure our civil affairs
such that on the one day in seven, which
God has deemed holy, we rest from our
work and worship him." This civil and
public acknowledgement should certainly
be formalized in our governing
documents.
>> We've shown up to teach you to obey. And
immediately they're like, "This is
jihad." Immediately, this is Sharia law.
Because they feel the force in some
sense, you just have to lean into it.
You can't back down on the obedience
part. You're just like,
>> we're absolutely here to teach people to
obey the standard.
>> Yeah.
>> Our concern is is that long-term down
the road, our people are going to be
facing imprisonment in the future as
they did back in 1888.
>> And if that were to happen, that would
be bad. But it would be way better than
what you're going through now.
>> How so?
>> You said earlier that you want this to
be a Christian world. Yes.
>> So you want to supplant their religion
with your Christian. I find it really
ironic though that that they're taking a
pretty hard stance with we need to do
this, like we need to bake this back
into our governmental system.
>> And yet we have things like pornography
in our world.
>> We have movies that completely blaspheme
God.
>> Yes.
>> We have a religious organization that's
calling himself God. That's supposedly
sitting in the seat of God.
>> That's blasphemous.
>> So where's all those people enforcing
that? But it's like all of a sudden it's
just going to be like guns blazing down
to the day.
>> Yeah. I mean I mean that's what you're
seeing is that there's there's this
great emphasis towards the day.
>> Um why?
>> Yeah. What about the other stuff?
>> Right.
>> I mean at least be consistent, right? If
you're going to legislate against that,
then take every ounce of pornography
away from the entire internet.
>> Right. Like why are you you're so you're
so
>> But you notice how he said it has to be
the first step that that that this has
to be that the blue laws have to be the
first step.
>> Yeah.
>> Um you know and there's there's more
discussion on this. I mean there I was
just wondering I wonder if that's
intentional in that if you have a lack
of options on a particular day
>> are you going to fill up your churches?
And if your churches are full, then you
can continue the narrative more
succinctly, I guess, to everybody. You
get everybody on the same page, like,
okay, we got them all here. Now, let's
tell them where this whole thing is
going and what we want.
>> I'm sure. Yeah. I mean, it makes logical
sense from that from that viewpoint.
Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Um, but you know, Jared
Longshore and Lennux Kolafonga, they
have a they had a podcast discussion and
they were talking about morality. um and
and see what they have to say about it.
>> Has our society decided that we're going
to legislate standards that are based
upon the standards that God has revealed
to us? And we haven't done that yet. I
think Christians need to fill that space
um and fill it loudly
>> at this juncture.
>> Yeah.
>> Because we are going to find some more
stability for which we should be
thankful.
>> But we still have to make sure that we
go Yeah. And you need to legislate
morality.
>> Wow. Yeah. It's more more of the same.
Um, but you know, Dr. Taylor Marshall,
he's a a Catholic author and commentator
online. Um, and there is this
overarching
push to basically get rid of separation
of church and state. Uh, take a listen
to what he has to say about
>> this is from 1864.
It's Pope Pas the 9th. He wrote a
document called the syllabus of errors.
All right. He listed things that were
erroneous, that were bad,
and he condemned them.
Here is one of the propositions,
Proposition 55,
that was condemned by the Pope. Quote,
right on the screen,
quote, "The church ought to be separated
from the state and the state from the
church." End quote. This proposition was
condemned as heretical.
All right? So if you make this
proposition
that is condemned that is anathema that
is heretical.
If you are a Catholic you cannot say
this and I quote the church ought to be
separated from the state and the state
from the church.
What is Pope Pas I 9th teaching us? He's
teaching us that there is a true
integration
of the church and of the state. So the
church has the vocation, the call and
the graces to elevate the state.
It can call the state to have a Catholic
understanding of matrimony, of family,
of adoption, of laws, of just war, of
usery. And this is exactly what should
happen. And in successful Catholic
countries, Christian countries,
historical, that is what happened. Were
there abuses? Yes. Guess what? Humans
and their concupisence from original sin
kicks in. People submit to evil.
But the proper arrangement
is the Catholic one. And that is an
integration of church and state. State
in its lane. Church in its lane. But
integrated. What are your thoughts on
that?
>> Except except he's basically saying I I
understand he says integration. I
understand he says lanes but at the same
time the church is the one supposed to
be communicating to the state which
suggests a hierarchy.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. Yep.
>> And in that hierarchy in history if you
look that was a huge power struggle and
it never worked out very well for the
state.
>> It always worked out in favor of the
church and the papacy. Always. I like
how he's like, you know, talking about
the morality issue needs to be like
combined like this that and we need to
do it the Catholic way because
>> Yeah. have it right. Of course,
>> which, you know, I would expect nothing
less because he is Catholic.
>> But but that is the the Catholic
sentiment really.
>> You know, you're seeing a a large push
though across Protestant America as
well. Um, you know, here's Congressman
Andy Ogles and he posted this uh online
and he said, "We must stand and reaffirm
that this is a Christian nation. Uh,
this is a Christian nation. This is a
battle of good versus evil.
>> It's a crusade."
That's essentially what he's
>> I mean, yeah, just putting that imagery
right there. There were some terrible
things that were crusade were done
during this period.
>> Yep. Um you have uh other uh social
media accounts like the Knights
Templars, you know, all pointing their
swords at one thing. Christ is king of
all nations. And you're actually seeing
this push. Um there's actually multiple
articles that have been trying to
proclaim Christ as king. Christ is king.
Christ is king. Um and this is something
that you really saw echoed previously as
well. This is not a new concept to
decare to declare Christ as king. And it
actually has Catholic origins to it.
But, you know, you have you have uh
multiple other social media accounts
that are talking about it. You have the
Knights Templars pushing forward uh
Christian nationalist imagery having a
you know, what is this like a priest in
front of a church with an
>> AR? Yeah. Whoever whoever made this
picture has played way too
>> like Assassin's Creed video games.
>> Yeah. But I mean, you know, Christ said,
"My kingdom is not of this world."
And that's where I think these these
guys are misunderstanding that they feel
like they have to establish Christ's
kingdom by force.
>> Yeah.
>> But that was never the way of Christ.
>> And the Bible's plain. When Jesus comes,
he will be in the air. And many that are
that are raised will be caught up with
him in the air.
>> The seven mountain mandate kind of
predicates itself on like we need to
take control over all these areas, these
seven mountains in order for Jesus to
come back. But when you look at the
Bible and Jesus says he he's when he
comes back, the earth is in shambles.
>> It's not all set up perfectly by
Christians so he can return. So there's
a disconnect there.
>> Yeah, very much so. Um but you know,
you've also had the Heritage Foundation.
Um and here's a little clip talking
about basically their plans for uh 2026.
Um take take a look at this
>> from the people who brought you Project
2025. Prepare yourself for 2026. The
Heritage Foundation's policy priorities
are out for next year, and they are
building on what the Trump
administration has already achieved. The
conservative movement is calling it the
golden age of choice.
The golden age is a choice.
It's a choice to prioritize families and
empower local communities.
>> A choice to find dignity in prosperous
and honorable work. a choice to
prioritize our nation's safety,
protecting our homeland, and standing
strong against foreign threats.
>> Joining me now, David Graham, staff
writer for The Atlantic and author of
The Project: How Project 2025 is
Reshaping America. David, welcome. Good
to have you on the show here. So next
year's wish list, which was originally
released in March, it it's not quite the
900page document that project 2025 was,
but how do their plans build on what
they've achieved thus far?
>> So, you know, you you also have uh this
special report basically that they
published, which was their blueprint
essentially for the next 250 years
because you know, this year um 2026 is
the 250th
>> Yeah.
>> year of this country.
>> It is
>> because it was founded in 1776. And so
they're they had like a whole thing
going on in Washington DC where
throughout the summer basically they
have a ton of events up there and
they're having a day of prayer like a
national day of prayer on the National
Mall. Um Oh wow. That that is going
forward at that time.
>> So um basically they're saying you know
we've become the most powerful country
in the world in 250 years. Where does
the next 250 years take us? And what is
interesting is if you look in the body
of this document
there is discussion about a uniform day
of rest. and they talk about blue laws.
>> Um, and they say that basically these
persist in some form in close to 28
states and these places serve as a sort
of legal reservoir. Um, once their day
of rest laws are abolished, they are
very hard to restore.
>> And then kind of the answer to that
sentence is in the next sentence. It
says, "A uniform day of rest that limits
commercial activity can provide temporal
boundaries that help communities to set
aside time for religious observance,
family gatherings, outdoor activities,
and rest." So basically, you know, these
localized blue laws that we have in
states, well, those they get abolished,
they're hard to restore. A uniform day.
What is that pushing?
>> Well, yeah. One day of worship, uniform,
>> uniform, right? That's federal, right?
Right. Right.
>> So that would be a a national Sunday
law.
>> I think in different parts of the world,
they have tried to a certain degree
these different ways where there you can
pick and choose a day and it just didn't
work out. Didn't pan out. So, they're
going to use that as evidence to be
like, "Yeah, okay. You can't just like
pick and choose the day because then
that still makes everybody work and
>> you know, we need to actually
collectively do this on this day,
>> right?" So, that that kind of is the the
ultimate conclusion that I think we kind
of have to talk about then is if they're
pushing forward a day of rest on Sunday,
which that's what it says is it says
that it would be on Sunday, right?
Sunday closing laws. Um, if they push
that forward,
where does that leave people who study
the Bible and come to the understanding
that you don't find a change from
Saturday to Sunday in scripture? There's
no scriptural authority for it. The
Roman Catholic Church has said, "Yeah,
we changed that."
What happens to the people that are are
solos scriptor and believe the Bible and
the Bible alone? Well, if they do the
same thing that, you know, the
government is really enforcing this
thing. So, that's going to be tied into
labor, okay? Because they got to stop
everybody. So, the labor laws and all
this kind of stuff have to fit within
this construct. You're going to have a
challenge making a living,
>> right?
>> That's pretty much ultimately what your
decision is going to cost us. If we
either play ball or we don't, then
that's the you're going to lose out. And
if everybody's on whatever financial
system they have here,
>> I mean, they're going to get turned on
or off. I mean, you're not really in
control of that anymore.
>> Right. Right. So, I think this is
pushing us towards a dangerous
combination. If you look back in
history, every time there's been a union
of church and state, it has resulted in
persecution.
>> Yeah.
>> And I think that we are facing that
right now. And so, it's our duty to wake
up and realize the times that we're
living in. Lift up our heads for our
redemption drawth nigh. We have a duty
to warn the world about this dangerous
combination. You know, you guys have a
video on your channel talking about the
mark of the beast and what that is. And
I think that this is ultimately where
this is leading.
>> Yep. I believe so, too.